[Música]
[Aplausos]
la comunicación
cuántos crímenes se cometen en su nombre
no pasa un día sin que escuché a alguien
protestar por la comunicación
que no nos comunican bien que tenemos
problemas de comunicación que gobiernan
nos separamos porque teníamos que darle
más
incompatibles
insoportables
no tienen
sin embargo
hace un tiempo es hacer un mantra que
repetimos todos nuestros
la historia de la humanidad en él son
gratis
se van a bruno los condenados y los
tipos dijeron que no supimos cómo
pero sí
en esta jornada estamos como hiper
comunicados super conectado más que
nunca en la historia de la humanidad es
en el faro
con tanta comunicación nunca nos
sentimos tan incomunicados
esto empezó con la tele donde esta
aparición de los medios nos genera mucho
miedo en los 60 discutíamos que los que
iba a ser la televisión de nuestra
cabeza cómo iba a ser que esos
contenidos producida por los extraños
con malas intenciones en nuestras casas
entonces hoy apareció la primera la
primera solución de control en la
televisión pero no pasó antes también
con la radio ahora
descubrimos el experimento dorso
es tan poderoso como decía no exagerar a
los diarios porque como apareció la
radio también tenía mucho miedo de lo
que la radio le iba a hacer a la
sociedad piensen que apenas
este señor que se llama marshall mcluhan
dijo que íbamos a estar todos
comunicados entre sí conectados en una
gran aldea global y que eso iba a ser
posible con unos dispositivos y ahora
saltan pequeñitos que los íbamos a
cargar
sí no
y la tarea en junio
era demasiado fantasioso en esa época
con leer al pato donald
y el pato donald
es el miedo contemporáneo envío
contemporáneos a las redes
las redes sociales nos generan muchísimo
miedo sin embargo pasamos mucho tiempo
en ellas
además teníamos miedo a los contenidos
de la televisión y ahora que los nuevos
pedirá medidas iguales los contenidos
que más pedimos
primero consumimos en internet
por no hablar
el 80 años
ya está la ventana
en la sociedad tiene casi todos el de
más del 80 por ciento de los
latinoamericanos aún en las clases más
pobres tienen teléfonos celular
y más de 60 tenemos banda ancha y densa
y el 50 por ciento somos para las redes
sociales es decir que el 70 por ciento
del uso que le damos al teléfono tiene
que ver con las redes estas distintas
redes que tenemos
en los que pasamos
horas 44 minutos con el teléfono por vía
y que tres horas y media en redes
sociales o sea que nos quedan 15 minutos
para consultar el mel para contestar
y bastante asombroso de nuevo cuando
empezamos a tener redes sociales hace 14
años recipiente de acuerdo a cómo se
comunicaban con la gente que estaban
lejos
hace 8 que no teníamos pasado
el mundo feliz pero la verdad no sé cómo
me podría organizar el día sin whatsapp
[Música]
pero bueno esto obviamente nos generó
nuevas
ahora tenemos que aprender a manejar una
computadora tenemos que aprender a
manejar la computadora tenemos que
aprender a manejar el teléfono hace
apenas
diez años nadie creía que íbamos a ser
capaces de escribir con el pulgar en un
teclado de 12 teclas y más mucho más
lejos y ahora vivimos sin peleado y van
a los mensajes y mandamos audios y
nuevos audios y mandamos audios y mandan
los audios y mandamos audios
la comunicación se nos volvió algo
omnipresente se nos volvió una
obligación ahora tenemos que estar
comunicados cada vez que recibimos un
mensaje una llamada nuestra primera
pregunta es dónde estás
cuando nos vean dame un mensajito cuando
llegaste
necesitamos todo el tiempo esa lógica de
la comunicación pero de todas las
obligaciones de la comunicación a mí la
que más me inquieta es la de la imagen
tenemos que fotografiar todo
no hace tanto que cuando nos íbamos de
vacaciones con un rollo de 36
exposiciones arreglamos los 15 días
después había que revelar la así era un
problema de 36 fotos sacamos por día y
nadie sabe muy bien que vamos a hacer
con esa cantidad de terabytes de
imágenes de cumpleaños quedadas cenas y
cosas muchos menos contables en una
charla como ésta
y las guardamos vas a saber para aquí
de la peor desde esas obligaciones de la
imagen es esta de la de las el fin las
ocho de la mañana se llevó a la
universidad y me dice profe profe
sacamos una foto
a esa hora y estas edades a no estoy
como para ya no me corrige ni el beauty
face del teléfono
y tampoco soy mirtha legrand ahí me
encantaría hacer mirtha legrand chilenos
al final es el fino pero entonces bueno
más mega nada más el afecto y dale nos
sacamos la foto y después padezco todo
el día esa foto horrible que circula por
las por internet y que manda un saludo a
gente incluso que uno no quisiera que la
vieran estas trazas pero esa idea de que
tenemos que registrar todo también se ha
vuelto una obligación de este nuevo
sistema de comunicación el otro es el de
y es el más duro y lo estamos sintiendo
en estos días es la obligación de
indignarse
las redes sociales nos obligan ya no
solo a informarnos nos obligan no solo a
participar sino nos obligan a
indignarnos y si no lo hacemos aparece
toda la patrulla moral de amigos
conocidos y no tantos que nos dicen cómo
lo compartiste el hashtag
como no mandaste la foto de la persona
perdida de la semana
como le pusiste me gusta a esa noticia
una carita triste le tenía que haber
puesto una carita enojada
como como no te compares es de que el
perrito este quedó abandonado
y esa esa visibilidad que tenemos de
nuestros sentimientos también se ha
vuelto una carga de este nuevo contexto
entonces lo que nos pasa es que la
comunicación que apenas en mil 948 la
declaración universal de derechos
humanos había consagrado justamente como
un derecho ese derecho a expresarnos a
informarnos a acceder a medios de
comunicación en el siglo 21 se nos ha
vuelto una penosa obligación
y ahí es que algunas soluciones
nos plantean también nuevos parámetros
de relación porque la gente se angustia
de que están con el telefonito en la
cena familiar
como si hace 30 años atrás todas las
cenas familiares transcurrieran padres
que tal ha sido su día o madre que
interesante la comida que ha preparado
hace 30 años miramos la televisión hace
50 escuchamos la radio dio razones para
alejarnos de lo que están cerca siempre
tuvimos lo que pasa que ahora lo podemos
hacer prácticamente entonces resulta que
además eso que antes estaba puertas
adentro hoy lo compartimos todo el
tiempo compartimos las fotos de nuestros
niños cuando fíjense qué paradoja la ley
prohíbe a los medios tradicionales
exhibir las fotos de los pequeñitos pero
los padres graciosamente las comparten a
toda hora porque es irresistible
compartir las monerías del nene
y compartir nuestros éxitos y compartir
los fracasos - porque lo que nos hemos
generado es esta burbuja de apariencia
esta burbuja de cierto modelo que
queremos mostrar a esos lejanos que
tenemos cerca porque los tenemos en el
celular entonces algunas de las
soluciones que nos dan en estos tiempos
es apaguemos las redes no como esos
carteles que aparecen que además son muy
festejados a mi facebook mira qué bien
hablen de entre ustedes no tenemos wifi
y qué hacen ustedes en el wifi yo hablo
hablo también entre ustedes con el wifi
entonces resulta que una desventaja
pretenden pasarla por virtud
cuando justamente lo interesante de
estos tiempos es que hemos desafiado uno
de los mandatos más firmes del siglo
pasado que es no hables con extraños hoy
justamente las redes nos permiten todo
el tiempo estar hablando con extraños y
esto va a tener impactos necesariamente
está en el nuevo orden mundial porque de
pronto empezamos a darnos cuenta que
otros países están pasando por las
mismas cosas que pasamos a otras
personas están pasando por situaciones
que son incluso mucho más graves de
aquellas de las que nos quejamos y
necesariamente eso tiene que ver con el
mutuo entendimiento yo no quiero estar
en un negocio donde no tengan wifi yo no
quiero estar en una institución
educativa donde no no tengan wifi porque
con la excusa de que los chicos se
distraen con los celulares quién soy yo
para prohibirles a los chicos acceder en
el momento de la clase al libro que yo
estoy citando al vídeo que yo les estoy
mostrando al programa del que le estoy
hablando
a un diccionario que podemos consultar
en línea
creo que
la comunicación es nuestro archivo
expiatorio favorito pero porque estamos
en un ataque de bulimia de comunicación
estamos demasiado pendientes de la
comunicación y necesitamos ponernos a
dieta necesitamos empezar a depurar un
poco esto porque porque a pesar de que
los canales se multiplicaron que los
mensajes se multiplicaron nuestra
atención sigue siendo la misma tenemos
el mismo tiempo disponible sino bastante
menos que los que tenían nuestros padres
o nuestros abuelos
por lo tanto el tiempo que le dedicamos
a la comunicación frívola innecesaria se
la estamos restando a esa comunicación
importante yo les decía no quiero estar
con comunicación sin conexión porque a
mí la conexión me trae el mensaje de mi
amado la invitación que no esperaba la
advertencia de la que no tenía previsión
pero que justamente me ordena para salir
de casa con el tiempo y con los recaudos
necesarios yo quiero estar en un mundo
conectado pero no quiero estar en un
mundo frívolamente conectado
cuántos de ustedes están dispuestos a
revisar lo que están haciendo con sus
redes de comunicación cuántos estarían
dispuestos a depurar esa red de amigos
virtuales que ya sabemos que no son los
mejores
cuántos están dispuestos a sacar del
facebook a la cuñada
eso que no soportan y que todos los días
que no les pusiste el me gusta la foto
de la comunión de carlitos no no me
interesan
no podemos ser sinceros presiona culpa
en facebook eso es culpa de vaya a saber
el rollo que yo tengo con la cuñada
cuántos estamos dispuestos a dejar de
leer consumir las noticias que nos dan
la razón para enfrentarnos a aquellos
medios y noticias que nos cuestionan
cuántos los animamos a salir de ser
círculo de protección de los cercanos en
el que estamos cómodos pero ajustados y
establecer redes mucho más expansivas
mucho más nutritivas mucho más abiertas
a la intercomprensión que tanto
necesitamos en estos tiempos
cuantos están dispuestos a aceptar esto
de que la solución es menos comunicación
por favor gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]